la nouvelle équipe autour d'Emmanuel
Macron alors n'attendez pas la photo de
famille de ce nouveau gouvernement il
n'y en aura pas le gouvernement que vous
constituez est avant toute chose comme
je l'évoquais dans cette même salle le 7
mai dernier un gouvernement pour agir et
qu'Emmanuel Macron avec Edouard Philippe
avec Alexis colère on était en face je
dis d'une matrice on est comme dans
Matrix on lorsqu'on veut essayer de de
discuter avec eux de faire de faire
resurgir la réalité des choses on efface
un programme informatique c'est pour ça
que j'ai parlé effectivement
d'algorithmes
[Musique]
ça c'est la patience de la droite
on était sur le Titanic et je continue à
le penser c'est à dire que il ne se
réinvente pas c'est toujours plus fort
plus vite sans changer quoi que ce soit
Emmanuel Macron court après Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Marine Le Pen court après
Jean-Luc Mélenchon LR se soumet à
Emmanuel Macron qui couche qui court
après Jean-Luc Mélenchon parce qu'il
vient de bercer
premier Conseil des ministres délicat
pour Damien Abad le ministre des
Solidarités est accusé de viol ce matin
il ne s'attarde pas devant les caméras
la question n'est pas sa démission à lui
mais le fait qu'il soit démi de ses
fonctions par principe de précaution il
y a deux il y a deux témoignages de
femmes qui ne se connaissent pas qui
sont concordants qui relate des faits
qui sont assez similaires Sandrine
Rousseau et disqualifié pour dire quoi
que ce soit c'est quelqu'un qui est
depuis un an fait de la politique en se
présentant ecoféministe c'est-à-dire
écologiste et féministe elle n'a jamais
défendu aucune position écologique sur
aucun sujet ça fait un an qu'elle nous
pardonnez-moi le mot bassine avec le
féminisme et quand il y a une affaire
dans sa propre famille politique elle
explique qu'il faut pas porter plainte
et que ça doit être réglé en interne par
un bureau interne de la France insoumise
nous n'avons pas de commentaires à faire
encore une fois la première ligne s'est
exprimée ce matin on la laissera
s'exprimer de nouveau si elle le
souhaite je pense que par ailleurs elle
a été très claire si j'étais Premier
ministre je dirais à Damien Abad je n'ai
pas de raison particulière de penser que
les femmes mentent la parole des femmes
doit être respectées et donc dans
l'attente d'une décision de justice et
bien je souhaite que tu ne sois pas au
gouvernement porter plainte au
commissariat un an après mais j'ai pas
réussi à signer à aller jusqu'au bout
mais six ans plus tard j'ai réussi à le
faire c'est parce que Damien était
omniprésent dans les médias et que je
pouvais plus supporter juste de le voir
d'en souffrir et que lui ne soit
inquiété en rien
une polémique que la première ministre a
tenté d'esquiver cet après-midi pas
d'allusion du chef de l'État à cette
polémique mais à l'issue du conseil la
nouvelle porte-parole rappelle la ligne
du président la justice
et la seule à devoir et à pouvoir
trancher
à ma connaissance
au moment où nous nous parlons
aucune autre procédure n'est en cours à
l'endroit de Damien Abad j'ai toujours
évité de mettre mon handicap en avant
j'étais contraint malheureusement de le
faire aujourd'hui pour me défendre et
même de dévoiler mon intimité en détail
en expliquant que les faits qui
mettaient imputés étaient matériellement
impossibles c'est assez assez poignant
parce que ce monsieur était handicapé
donc il explique que évidemment il ne
peut pas forcer aucune femme donc là on
tombe vraiment je suis très très mal à
l'aise si ces femmes ont raison
tort et si elles mentent
faut que chacun mesure la gravité de
tout ça
écoutez un homme innocent doit-il
démissionner je ne crois pas merci
beaucoup